pression de plusieurs dizaines de ses
marins poursuit l'offensive mais vient
d'évoquer la possibilité d'un cessez le
feu
paris un appel du gouvernement français
à l'arrêt immédiat des hostilités
et puis le chômage toujours au dessous
de la barre des 2 millions données
brutes mais en augmentation
en données corrigées la messieurs
bonsoir la guerre fait sans doute encore
rage dans l'atlantique sud autour des
malouines
bien que londres est tout à leur démenti
un affrontement naval en cours
pourtant les communiqués contraire se
succèdent les argentins auraient perdu à
un bombardier est l'un de leurs aviso
touchés par les britanniques regagne en
ce moment son port d'attache les
britanniques eux pleurent ce soir la
perte de leurs destroyer sheffield en
fait le bâtiment est toujours à flot
mais devra sans doute être coulés par
ses propres amis
il est désormais inutilisable mais ce
qui est plus grave bien sûr c'est qu'une
trentaine de marins ont disparu dans
l'incendié du bateau et l'opinion
britannique a vécu durement le choc ce
matin à la confirmation la nouvelle
bernard ap les anglais ont pu voir tout
à l'heure à la télévision ces images
kick de dix ans le baptême du sheffield
par la reine et c'est vrai la perte de
ce navire ressenti ici comme une
catastrophe nationale
les drapeaux ont été mis en berne un peu
partout dans le pays et notamment ici
par la ville de sheffield qui a donné
son nom au destroyer la surprise a été
totale il faut bien le dire les derniers
communiqués du ministère britannique de
la défense avait en effet accréditer
l'idée que la flotte anglaise était
intouchable
pourtant hier soir le drame était bien
et espère n'existe qu'une seule toute la
nuit dernière et aujourd'hui encore la
télévision et les radios ont diffusé une
longue liste de numéros de téléphone
c'est là que les parents de l'équipage
du chef ils peuvent appeler pour avoir
des nouvelles
la plupart des marins du destroyer
venaient de la région de portsmouth et
ce matin les réactions aux alentours du
port reflétait la consternation
j'avais beaucoup de copains sur le
bateau jamais fait très mal d'apprendre
ça c'est pas bien quoi dire ça m'a
beaucoup choqué tous que c'est horrible
on n'aurait jamais pensé qu'on puisse en
arriver là surtout à nos navires qu'il
faut faire sauter tous ces argentins
dire je sais pas ce qu'on attend je sais
pas ce qu'on attend du jusqu'aujourd'hui
faut tous les faire sauter tout faire
sous la colère et l'inquiétude
on les retrouve aussi chez les familles
des marins qui habitent ici dans la cité
navale de portsmouth
on aurait jamais pu penser que ça aurait
pu aller aussi loin
vous pensez que c'était juste la sphère
de 15 jours mais maintenant personne ne
veut plus abandonné
s'ils peuvent faire sauter un bateau en
france aux côtés d'autres la presse de
son côté consacre bien sûr ces titres à
l'événement des normes titre encadré
d'un filet noir on peut dire simplement
un de nos bateaux a été coulé par les
argentins les triomphes d'hier a cédé là
encore la place à quelque chose qui
ressemble à de la stupeur et ce soir
dans les salles de rédactions
britanniques chacun attend les derniers
détails et surtout le dernier bilan du
drame survenu hier freitas 1000km de
l'angleterre
alors justement maintenant il faut
revenir sur les conditions de la tacc
réussie du destroyer chez fil par un
avion argentin étendard de fabrication
française donc qui a lancé un missile
exocet même origine un missile étonnant
dont patrick lecocq nous rappeler les
propriétés l'évolution de la guerre en
1914 par exemple pour couler un cuirassé
il fallait d'abord le voir avant de
tirer au canon en 1943 il fallait
détecter le bateau avec un radar et
envoyé des avions pour le bombardé
aujourd'hui il semble qu'il suffit de
larguer un missile à une bonne distance
le pilote de l'avion ne voit pas sa
cible sinon sur son radar et les marins
ne voit pas l'avion
sinon sur leur radar aujourd'hui c'est
l'électronique qui fait tout ou presque
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
la guerre sur mer un avion armé d'un
seul missile a coulé un grand bâtiment
de combat 650 kg contre 4000 tonnes
ce missile s'appelle line 39 il fait
partie de la famille des exocet
construit par l'as niasse outre la
marine française cette famille des
engins équipe 25 nations le véhicule
porteur c'est le super étendard un
appareil construit par la société
breguet dassault qui équipe la marine
nationale est qui et qui a été commandé
par l'argentine en quatorze exemplaires
selon paris cinq ont été livrés en
juillet dernier buenos aires affirme en
posséder 12
ce couple super étendard missiles am39
est une arme redoutable
on en a eu la preuve hier à l'oreiller
ajustements 2006 la n 39 ont été tirés
on en déduit que l'un d'entre eux a raté
sa cible et la probabilité de réussite
du tir est très forte mais elle
n'atteint tout de même pas 100 %
notamment lorsque le bâtiment attaqué et
ultramoderne est destiné à la lutte anti
aérienne nous sommes d'ailleurs pas
certain de l'échec du deuxième missile
selon les argentins le deuxième exercice
aurait touché un autre bateau un bateau
plus grand d'ailleurs que le sheffield
si cette information
est confirmée on est obligé de penser
que l'un des deux porte avions
britannique a été touché alors pour
éviter un missile du type de l'exo 7 à
sa tante de procédure sont possibles les
contre mesures passives et qu'on appelle
les contre mesures actives des contre
mesures passives
cela consiste tout simplement à faire le
silence radio absolu à bord du bâtiment
plus de radio plus de radars plus de
machines le bateau devient à la fois
aveugle et sourd c'est tout de même un
inconvénient majeur il devient très
vulnérable à d'autres attaques et
notamment à d'autres attaques d'exo 7
les contre mesures actives elles font
entrer en ligne de compte d'autres
éléments notamment l'électronique mais
aussi ce que l'on appelle les shafts ou
les leurs
l'objectif est de fournir à l'auto
directeur du missile une image plus
alléchante dirais-je de la cible qui a
été choisi par le pilote
alors là il ya plusieurs méthodes l'une
d'entre elles consiste tout simplement
comme d'ailleurs durant la dernière
guerre a créé un nuage de brindilles
métallique qui se déplace et qui
s'éloigne peu à peu du navire visé ce
nuage de brindilles prend des formes
prend de la taille
il devient plus grand que le bateau et
les autos messieurs willow taux
directeurs du missile se retrouve avec
deux images devant lui et il choisit
celle qui me semble la plus intéressante
donc la plus grosse et là il se perd en
mer ce procédé est efficace contre une
attaque menée par un seul avion est donc
un seul missile hier contre domicile le
sheffield n'avait aucune chance
même en réagissant très très vite voilà
vous le disiez à venise et on laisse
entendre qu'un autre navire britannique
aurait été touché que deux avions à
décollage vertical auraient été abattus
par ailleurs on minimise ce soir là bas
les pertes du croiseur général belgrano
on ne parle plus que de 250 victimes
d'un instant à l'autre nous devrions
entrer en liaison avec notre
correspondant sur place
lotbinière et apparemment ne m'entends
pas pour l'instant en revanche à londres
toujours en direct et aux côtés de
bernard rapp un député cette fois ci non
plus conservateurs mais travailliste
bernard donc un député de l'opposition a
même satcher alors j'ai tout de suite
envie de
vous demandez mr robinson si vous êtes
d'accord avec le numéro 2 de votre part
de votre parti monsieur danis et les qui
jugé que justement on allait peut-être
un petit peu trop loin avec cette
escalade de la guerre
oui on ne l'a pas voulu on a voulu la
situation une situation de force faut
négocier et de ne pas devoir accepter ce
qu'avait fait de d'illégal l'argent
d'argentine voilà ce qu'on a voulu
est ce qu'on veut encore c'est quand
même que tous les deux parties il faut
être en deux pour le faire qu'il y ait
cette se cessent de feu là bas on ne
veut encore et pour nous il faut rester
dans la zone de 200 milles qui est une
zone exclusive rester dedans mais il
semble t'il selon les informations qui
coule ici à londres rien de nouveau une
grande bataille là bas mais à vous
écouter l'opinion tout entière
britannique donc ne se trouve pas
d'ailleurs à mme thatcher et à pour une
partie envie que ça cesse c'est à dire
que quand on vient de perdre un grand
bateau un des souayah c'est une grand
choc mais ce conte tout le monde on en
veut tu es d'accord quand même de
soutenir le principe au pour laquelle on
a avancé ce task force et sa touche
maintenant à tout le monde aussi aux
argentins eux mêmes devoirs que vraiment
cette carte vie des deux côtés il faut
l'arrêter c'est on dit maintenant on y
lire que 250 argentins qui ont dit-il tu
es qui ont été qui ont une qui sont
morts dans la mer moi ce sont 250 trop
il faut aller à la table de conférence
et de la housse est où le problème doit
à la fin se résoudre pas sur la mer ou
en l'air et tout à l'heure votre
ministre des avait des projets à francis
pim a évoqué la possibilité à cesser le
feu vous pensez que c'est réellement
possible
ça dépend dirige des argentins 7e qui
ont commencé ils doivent quand même dire
que les possibilités de négociations
existent ça a été la position qui a
prises madame ça tient qu'a pris surtout
le parti travailliste ici en angleterre
en grande bretagne et on y reste
il faut négocier ce problème et pas en
faire une guerre
peut quand même escaladé encore de plus
voilà je vais vous demander de rester
avec nous encore un moment monsieur
robinson parce que nous allons peut-être
avoir tout à l'heure en direct de buenos
aires le témoignage d'un journaliste
argentin il serait intéressant de
confronter vos deux points alors à
l'étranger les réactions se sont
multipliées aujourd'hui le pape s'est
déclaré profondément frappé par
l'aggravation des combats la maison
blanche a souligné la dissolution
urgente donc la nécessité urgente d'une
solution pacifique
paris enfin demandé l'arrêt immédiat des
combats au terme du contre les milices
naturellement préoccupés de la situation
dans cette région du monde et il a
déploré la mort de combattants de part
et d'autre dans ce qui ressemble
maintenant à une véritable guerre qui
oppose la grande bretagne à l'argentine
alors le conseil des ministres a demandé
que l'on en revienne à la résolution 502
adoptée par le conseil de sécurité
cette résolution ainsi que vous le savez
demande l'évacuation par les troupes
argentines d'asile fac landes
d'autre part des négociations entre
l'arrêt de socialité naturellement et
des négociations pour aboutir à une
solution pacifique du conflit alors le
congé démons se tient régulièrement
informé et en liaison aussi d'ailleurs
avec nos partenaires de la communauté
sur cette question
très grave la priorité pour la france et
donc l'arrêt des combats
merci naturellement l'arrêt des combats
est la recherche d'une solution
pacifique dans le respect du droit
international qui a été violé par
l'occupation par les troupes argentines
des îles shetland
mais il faut que les parties prenantes
au conflit discute et trouve une
solution canton vice-président du
conseil d'état cubain à l'heure actuelle
en visite en france il a condamné aux
côtés de georges marchais ce qu'il a
appelé les manoeuvres de l'impérialisme
il a été reçu en fin d'après-midi par
françois me taire voilà je fais une
dernière tentative avec buenos aires est
ce que claude gaignierre ou bruno albin
nous entendre oui très bien allez-y
claude claude gaignierre c'est à vous je
crois que nous n'avons pas de liaisons
possibles entre nous deux mais allez-y
ne paraît pas venir de paris bien
apparemment difficile d'avoir cette
liaison je le vois sur mon écran de
contrôle
si nous l'entendons il ne manquant pas
ces deux matches nous allons le
retrouver dans quelques secondes le
temps que nous fassions disons la revue
du reste des informations très bref
ailleurs à l'étranger encore si jeune
palestinien tué bc pardon par balles par
les militaires israéliens dans la bande
de gaza peu d'informations de pologne il
semble que lech walesa a été transféré
près de la frontière soviétique pour
éviter qu'il ne puisse trop parlé en
irlande le premier anniversaire de la
mort de bobby sands une manifestation
cet après-midi de soutien à paris un
attentat près de bilbao en espagne la
mort d'un responsable de la compagnie
chargé de la construction d'une centrale
nucléaire en espagne ou non loin de là
d'ailleurs près de santander
deux trains sont entrés en collision
cinq morts une vingtaine de blessés
et puis le conflit irak iran bagdad
parle d'une déroute des forces
iraniennes qui se serait effondré 20000
morts contre 6 cents seulement chez les
irakiens
voilà en attendant de revenir aux
malouines avec ce débat que j'espère
pouvoir organiser en direct sur
l'antenne donc entre buenos aires et
londres
nous emmenons
l'actualité française à commencer par ce
chiffre celui du chômage un chiffre
difficile à interpréter ce mois ci car
en données brutes le nombre des
demandeurs d'emploi reste bien inférieur
à 2 millions mais en données corrigées
des variations saisonnières la hausse
est de 1,2 pour cent on reste quand même
tout juste sous cette barre très
exactement 1 million 900 91000 le
conflit citroën et bien les négociations
se poursuivent toujours à aulnay il ya
eu des incidents aujourd'hui à metz et à
levallois apparemment la cgt a bien
décidé d'en découdre avec une autre
centrale syndicale on parle beaucoup
plus rarement que mais qu est très
présente dans un certain nombre d'autres
bros d'entreprise
la confédération des syndicats libres
manifestation aujourd'hui à paris des
grévistes citroën d'aulnay-sous-bois
soutenus par la cgt la cfdt et fo qui
réclame 400 francs par mois mais
derrière cette apparence le conflit
oppose la cgt et la csl les deux
organisations paissent dans l'automobile
le même poids et la querelle les
affrontements ne date pas d'hier
dans cette bataille violente la cgt y a
perdu un de ses militants pierre m il y
a quelques années
aujourd'hui c'est la guerre que ces
travailleurs qui sont soumis à la
pression et de la direction à la
répression et aux agressions de cette
direction il officiait csn entend
naturellement entendent naturellement
aboutir positivement voir ce conflit
aboutir positivement
j'ajoute que dans les heures qui
viennent de s'écouler à levallois trois
militants de la cgt ont été agressés par
la csl ont été hospitalisés que cette
nuit à l' usine d'eau m concernant
citroën met un représentant syndical cgt
a été agressé chez lui par un commando
de la csl la csl qui annonce près de 300
mille adhérents est essentiellement
implantée dans l'automobile
particulièrement chez citroën est talbot
les grévistes de l'accusé ce n'est pas
nouveau d'être un syndicat patronal
à la csl c'est le patron c'est la police
de patron c'est le point que pour nous
il est proche de ça à mon avis preuves
mais des preuves
l'astuce c'est ça la preuve on vous
montre là les cartes de la csn les gars
il a pris sa carte il a pillé sans frais
aujourd'hui elle servait l agité partir
moi je la vends ma c'est envoyer un sens
fera chaque art
hoyé garde là dedans qu'est ce qu'il ya
dedans ça en avait fait un permis de
travail ça si lui qui l'a pas ça il peut
pas travailler tranquillement
il ya toujours là ça pour moi pour moi
c'est un permis de travail b l'hostilité
dont elle est l'objet la csn prêtons
toujours être un syndicat à part entière
il faut bien admettre que le souffle du
changement depuis le 10 mai lui a porté
un rude coup les grévistes de citroën
réagisse car ils ont le sentiment
aujourd'hui qu'ils peuvent relever la
tête
la direction du groupe peugeot
s'interroge elle aussi aujourd'hui la
présence d'une organisation comme la csl
avec ce qu'elle draine de haine et de
passion n'est-elle pas plus un handicap
qu'un avantage
voilà michel lalanne notre chef
d'édition qui me signale que il est
possible désormais d'entrer en contact
avec buenos aires clos gaignierre vous
entendez oui enfin paraît pas très bien
est-ce que vous il vous semble qu'il y
ait la même prise de conscience qu'à
londres
aujourd'hui ce soir à buenos aires et
que on se disent on va peut-être un peu
trop loin dans ce conflit
écoutez n'ayant pas entendu le début de
votre journal
je ne sais pas exactement ce que vous
appelez par prise de conscience et quand
vous dites on va trop loin dans ce
conflit je n'ai pas du tout l'impression
que ce soit le cas des argentins ils
trouvent que les anglais vont trop loin
se défendent et on sent ici beaucoup de
détermination mais peut-être qu'on
pourrait poser la question à notre
invité qui est à côté de moi qui
s'appelle louis gatineau et qui est
journaliste argentin est ce que vous
croyez aujourd'hui qu'effectivement les
argentins pense nous sommes allés trop
loin
je pense que vraiment vous avez raison
nous pensons que ce sont les anglais qui
sont allés trop loin
vraiment la vampire a pris position
défensive
il fallait la récupération des îles les
haies avril 5 houlette insel goutte de
sang anglais
essayez raisonnablement paix négociée
tout ça qu'ils pouvaient négocier mais
on a révélé à la forte mais c'est fait
et pas médiateur c'était un associé de
grande bretagne pour pression' et à
l'argentine
alors maintenant avec l'attak de la
flotte britannique avec laquelle nous
amène à ses pendants à moi on a répondu
mais je serais déçu
est-ce que vous souhaitez ce soir le
cessez-le-feu ou est-ce que vous allez
continuer ce pilonnage de part et
d'autre écoutez si vous parlez de
pilonnage par les pilonnages
britanniques contre les îles la gamme is
on ne peut pas pilonner la flotte s'il
ne s'approche pas on a parlé d'une trêve
demander des 48 heures je pense que si
cette trêve va servir pour que nouveau
transport des troupes comme on l'est
canberra qui se trouve sur la côte
occidentale d'afrique avec 3000 soldats
britanniques plus un bateau avec plus de
6 avril nous avions des porte-avions
s'approche à la flotte alors je pense
qu'on devra respecter cette trêve parce
que c'est une moquerie bon mais c'est un
conflit sans fin si on vous entend vous
deux est ce que mr bean sun qui se
trouve toujours à londres en principe
aux côtés de bernard rapp
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire à ce que
vous venez d'entendre delà de la bouche
de mon confrère argentin j'ai pas
tellement bien compris ce que nous
collègues argentin là bas il a dit mais
il continue l'asie en amoureux est-ce
qu'il est d'accord d'accepter la
résolution unanime du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu est-ce qu'il a esquivé
prêt à accepter si le rejette comme il
semble rejeter la médiation américaine
de monsieur est est-ce qu'il est prêt à
accepter la médiation soit 10 de l'onu
ou de pérou voilà il faut en finir de ce
conflit monsieur alors on pose la
question monsieur karassine houde est
prêt monsieur catinot bien sûr je
réponds monsieur robinson que
l'argentine a demandé la médiation de
l'onu est prête à l'accepter
de même elle a essayé de négocier avec
messier thé et je vous répète mais
c'était à démontrer que ce n'était pas
un médiateur
cyrano soucier de grande bretagne pour
pression' et à l'argentine voilà ma
vengeance
monsieur karassine auger l'occasion dû
perdre parler directement avec est-ce
que vous êtes prêts aussi d'accepter
l'esprit disons de la résolution 500 et
2 qui était unanime du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu parce que si on peut
pas dire d'un code d'un côté on accepte
l'onu et puis qu'on n'accepte pas ce
qu'a dit avec unanimité l'hogneau là
l'argentine a démontré qu'il est disposé
à accepter un cessez-le-feu et à
l'intervention de l'onu sous les
conditions de la vraie connaissance mais
sa souveraineté sur les îles malouines
préjugés le tout monsieur c'est trop
demander et vous voulez encore des
bateaux qui vont être cool et des
pilotes qui va encore nourrir là bas
parce que vous avez fait quelque chose
d'illégal
quelque chose qui a été condamnée du
tout le monde
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne va pas la cour
d'appel à la à la heg d'algues
il ya tellement de choses qu'on peut
faire pour éviter le conflit militaire
mais vous voulez préjugés et des
gociations est-ce que vous en avez peur
je pense qu'on avait montré qu'un n'a
pas peur messieurs reprise haussière y
écoutez moi monsieur robinson
je voudrais savoir vous êtes un membre
du parti travailliste
je vous pouvez vous poser une question
les gouvernements anglais vous informer
ponctuellement sur les perfs anglaise il
vous a signalé qu'il samedi 2 mai il est
quatre essais des débarquements
d'indécision et aurait pu pousser avec
d'énormes pertes anglaise il vous a
raconté qu'il a quatre frégates avariée
je vous racontais que les autres avions
hermès est touchée aussi le ministre et
je peux vous interrompre à tout ça ne
sert à rien en angleterre en bretagne on
a un parlement
on a des débats on se pose et on pose
aux autres les questions quand vous
aurez ça et si vous aviez ça même en
argentine peut-être qu'on ne sera pas
dans la situation où on en est
maintenant la chose c'est pas deux
de répondre cette méthode là c'est de se
dire est ce qu'on va résoudre cette ce
problème qui à la fin je vous assure
être résolus à la table de négociations
où est ce qu'on va encore sur les
escalades conflit militaire voilà la
question pour la touche maintenant à
vous avoue en argentine décider de ceux
ci à messieurs allons comme un bulldozer
nous sommes obligés d'arrêter pour des
questions d'impératifs horaire vous vous
en doutez bien et je crois qu'il est
souhaitable que je revienne maintenant à
l'antenne il est souhaitable que nous
arrêtions ce débat il était difficile à
organiser techniquement vous l'avez vu
mais je crois qu'il était assez
passionnant et je à ma connaissance est
une c'est une première nous avons pu
faire dialoguer londres et buenos aires
pour l'instant vous voyez le s'agit d'un
dialogue de sourds
mais je pense que avec ce genre
d'initiative on peut peut-être aider à
une solution disons plus pacifique de ce
conflit
un conflit là aussi muni nature tout à
fait différente un conflit social à la
rédaction d'antoinette le magazine
féminin de la cgt un conflit qui dure
les journalistes ont décidé de
reconduire leur grève pour protester
contre le licenciement de leur ipad
rédactrice en chef pardon et de
l'administratif du journal qui doit être
distel un magazine et non pas un
bulletin de propagande
nous diffuserons prochainement un
reportage sur ce confit de presse la
majorité n'a pas de leçon à donner à
l'opposition c'est simone veil qui l'a
dit tout à l'heure sur france inter la
gauche considère qu'elle est le bien
sorte d' angélisme extraordinaire et que
les autres sont le mal et non pas le
droit de s'exprimer
une déclaration qui vient donc au terme
d'une journée riche en accrochages entre
les deux blocs premier acte de la
journée une réunion commune udf rpr le
pouvoir socialo communistes cherchent à
dissimuler les échecs qui suivent ses
promesses
attaquer l'opposition est un moyen
commun pour rassembler ses partisans
dans une opération de diversion destinée
à faire oublier le mauvais bilan datant
de gouvernement le pouvoir
socialo-communiste hier si arrogants
visage
l'opposition passe aujourd'hui à
l'invectivé il ne montre finalement que
son désarroi le rpr et l'udf
continueront à jouer leur rôle
d'opposant dans le respect des règles
démocratiques
elles n'ont pas de leçons à recevoir de
ceux qui dans un passé récent attaquer
les institutions de la république avec
une violence excessive
parlant à leur sujet de coup d'état
permanent et qui lance aujourd'hui des
appels à l'unité nationale qui l'ont
compromise
il est anormal qu'un député sur ses
bancs attaque de cette façon l'actuel
président de la république
voilà votre manière voilée à votre
manière voilà l'opposition voilà le
visage
voilà le visage que vous montrer au pays
si vous voulez oublier ou entre le coach
j'ai pas d'oublier mais de passer au
dessus et au delà de ce que monsieur la
part air vient de rappeler de ce que je
pourrais rappelez moi même que j'ai eu
l'occasion de rappeler dans un
communiqué récemment mais de répondre à
l'appel du président de la république
pour que nous soyons les uns et les
autres ceux de la majorité et ceux de
l'opposition des français qui ont en
main et en charge les intérêts de la
france qui doivent dans la vigueur et
dans la fermeté faire connaître les
arguments mais qui doivent toujours
savoir qu'ils sont à l'assemblée
nationale ou au sénat
dépositaire d'une part c'est de la
souveraineté du peuple français et par
conséquent maintenir le débat
démocratique dans les limites du doit
être maintenu mais paul amar d'antenne
2010 nous avions parié tous les deux
cette même table sur de nouvelles
escarmouches c'était à prévoir
il fallait pas être devin pour imaginer
je crois que les changes entre andré
labarrère et les députés de l'opposition
illustre assez bien l'état des rapports
entre les deux camps on aurait pu penser
que la rencontre hier entre le président
mitterrand et jacques chirac allait
provoquer une éclaircie dans ce paysage
politique même si les deux hommes n'ont
parlé que de la pluie et du mauvais
temps mais ce n'est pas le cas le climat
est toujours à leur âge on l'a vu hier
avec la déclaration très ferme de pierre
mauroy qui a été notamment très choqué
par les propos de christian bonnet sur
robert badinter on l'a vu ce matin et
tout à l'heure donc dans ce journal
avec la déclaration de bernard fonce au
nom du rpr et de l'udf
alors le risque bien sûr c'est que ce
débat politique dérape ou que des
militants un peu trop zélé excusez-moi
prolonge le débat sur le terrain
ce risque les dirigeants politiques en
sont parfaitement conscients c'est
peut-être la raison pour laquelle le
françois mitterrand et jacques chirac
ont été très pudique hier ont préféré ne
pas en parler pour ne pas donner
l'impression d'accorder trop
d'importance à cette polémique c'est
aussi la raison pour laquelle pierre
mauroy a renouvelé l'appel à l'unité
lancé par françois mitterrand mais il
n'est pas sûr que ce voeu soit exaucé
par des hommes politiques qui dans les
deux camps tiennent actuellement des
propos assez durs et qui s'accusent
mutuellement de compromettre cette unité
ont conseil des ministres de ce matin un
hommage du chef de l'état la ténacité
est la conviction de son ministre de
l'agriculture et des cresson qui a
obtenu à bruxelles latine vit le
meilleur accord sur les prix agricoles
réalisés depuis longtemps par ailleurs
il a été confirmé que le secteur privé
dans les hôpitaux publics seraient
totalement supprimés d'ici le 1er
janvier 87 à la limite de l'hôpital la
maladie la pauvreté
voici en effet un portrait un peu
impressionnant réalisé par sylvie marion
et d'un mousse talo celui d'une femme
seule avec enfant qui vit à paris dans
une misère insoutenable est inimaginable
de l'extérieur un reportage réalisé
grâce au fichier du secours catholique
qui va tenir un congrès à la fin de la
semaine dans le noir est et qui ne cesse
depuis trois ans d'affirmer que
contrairement à toutes les idées reçues
la pauvreté s'aggrave dans la capitale
un tiers des 30000 parisien dépanné par
le secours catholique n'ont pas un sou
par jour
pour vivre sous la paume j'ai des
difficultés chacun a son amour propre
pour lui oui une personne sur deux
aidées par le secours catholique est une
femme seule comme menendez 36 ans quatre
enfants âgés de 12 à 16 ans rien ne
permet de soupçonner sa détresse en
apparence une ouvrière parmi d'autres à
paris criblé de dettes pourtant laissé
par un mari en prison pour elle se loger
manger dormir travailler vivre en amour
représente un effort de chaque instant
dans une biscuiterie fait un peu tout
vent aussi puisque je suis polyvalente
quand je vais fins de mois difficiles
chose qui arrive assez souvent je vais
dans les anges des embûches je cherche
une petite annonce
je vais déménager je laime du linge
heures passent
ça faisait des journées de 15 heures à
peu près
c'est une bien maison qui est vingt-deux
1924 donc aucun confort appel au boulot
froides chez les oies terme dans
l'appartement c'est tout mon appartement
près petits puisque les pièces sont de
10 mètres carrés vous voyez c'est 390 à
400 francs j'ai une d'électricité ici
pour ces quatre mois d'hiver qui s'élève
à 3 1 3170 francs pour manger en
brouille avec les moyens du bord un peu
parfois bon dos jettent des os et on
fait tout à fait avec une glace ou les
fruits j'en achète quelques fois la fin
de semaine pour des bleus dimanche en
regardant la télévision si on peut
manger une pomme sonore pour dormir tous
les soirs ces mêmes choses on est obligé
de plier les lits pour faire coucher 4
personnes 6
je les remets soit en instance de
divorce parce que de bons moments il
s'occupait pas nous c'est vrai et
envoyez pas pour nourrir les enfants et
moi-même
de plus il fait une grosse bêtise non je
trouve en prison parce qu'ils ne
contractent à rembourser pas mal de gens
puisque j'étais harcelé un jean et nuit
aussi bien par des visites par des coups
de fil
si vous cumulez montagne de dettes
vous gagnez combien par mois
3500 francs de quoi vous vous privez
plus d'eau de nourriture de distraction
de vêtements nous en font que mon fils
ait pas vu le film et non mais en fait
non pas voulu être filmée parce que veut
le garder la tête haute dans la rue à
l'école ils ont montré ce qu'est ce
qu'il vous faudrait beaucoup sortir de
cette situation intenable
est ce qu'il faudrait
que ce soit normal ben déjà une
assistance financière
ils vont travail bien payé
je ne sais pas qui de la compréhension
que oui la compréhension l'enlèvement de
jean-edern hallier l'écrivain à nouveau
chez juge d'instruction cet
après-midi-là porté plainte hier en
effet contre x et il trouve que depuis
sa disparition la presse n'a pas été
très charitable à son égard nous
l'entendrons s'exprimer dans notre
dernier journal les chiffres du loto tel
qu'il vient d'être tiré le 3 le 10 le
vin le 22 le 24 et le 28 avec
communément complémentaires le 33 et
puis les prévisions d'un gp très pour la
météo de demain
rabat ce sera vite dit demain nous
aurons encore un jour d'hiver car c'est
l'hiver il fait froid vous avez tous
constaté me après demain ça devrait
aller mieux alors pour demain soyons
bref le beau temps c'est uniquement sur
la méditerranée et la corse
peut-être davantage d'éclaircies l'après
midi sur le sud ouest mais pas beaucoup
le matin les rues de la neige sur les
pyrénées avait déjà et aujourd'hui sur
les deux tiers nord du pays c'est du
très mauvais temps avec une zone de
pluie de plus marquée du massif central
aux ardennes qui se décalera vers l'est
semaine aura de la neige à partir de 500
mètres d'altitude sur les vosges et le
jura sur une partie sur une grande
partie du nord ouest de la france ce
sera variable avec net annonce
d'éclaircies et de passages nuageux
accompagné de pluies de grêle d'orages
et de rafales de vent sous les averses
voilà les températures pour demain et
c'est assez clair c'est en baisse un
tour de france très rapide 12 à lille
ont adresse 12 à biarritz 17 à perpignan
14 à mulhouse et 12 à paris laissez-moi
deux secondes pour savoir la la planète
rouge demain les conseils de la jeunesse
pour les économies d'énergie tout est
rouge vous échauffer partout à
l'agression d'un militaire année notre
agenda demain jeudi 6 mai de minutes de
sommeil supplémentaires levé 6h24
coucher 21h11 et la fin de prudence qui
la merde tous les métiers régis bien sûr
voilà en sport j'apprends que le gardien
bordelais pente et les excès et celui
qui tire tous les penaltys et bien été
objet d'un an de suspension c'est d'une
sanction décidée tout à l'heure par la
commission de discipline de la
fédération française de football après
et l'a6 dans bordeaux lens du 13 avril
le tout dernier journal vous sera
présenté donc par jacques monod à 23h15
il vous reparlera bien entendu du
conflit des malouines et de du chômage
les deux gros titres de notre actualitté
d'aujourd'hui j'aurais quant à moi le
plaisir de vous retrouver à 20h et puis
demain à 12h45
philippe lavaud bonsoir merci à tous